hi everyone i'm william dennis a product
manager on google cloud working on gke
autopilot i'll be joined later by my
colleague gary who's going to take you
through a few demos
i'm excited to talk to you today about
gke's new autopilot mode of operation to
help streamline your application
delivery and management
before getting into the details of gk
auto part i'd like to quickly go over
some different options you have today
for deploying your applications
you can run them the traditional way on
vms directly using gce
or build them for serverless with cloud
run
and sitting in the middle is kubernetes
with gke
as you move up the layers of abstraction
from raw vms where you manage everything
through kubernetes which offers
container orchestration and management
to serverless where you just provide
your container to run your your
operations get easier as there's less
for you to manage but your deployment
choices and flexibility is a little bit
reduced as you go up the stack at the
same time
that's essentially the trade-off you're
trading the flexibility to deploy things
however you like with the need to manage
all that custom configuration
so what makes kubernetes the pop such a
popular choice
the main reasons i hear are that you
have some requirements that are not
necessarily solved by a higher order
product
while it's great if you can adapt
everything to your servers and frankly
speaking if you can i would recommend it
a lot of the time the reality is there's
just stuff you don't want to change
maybe you're bringing over a bunch of
existing applications maybe you need to
run a fairly complex deployment with
state that needs an attached persistent
disk
and sure in those cases people will tell
you hey you need to get rid of that
persistent disk and go use a managed
product and well they might be right
some of the time
but practically speaking it's not always
an option maybe the state is for a
custom database that you're the one
responsible for managing
maybe there is no managed solution
available or maybe you just don't want
to change things
kubernetes is a very practical
deployment environment which understands
that you have a lot of different
applications some legacy some new ones
and they have various requirements they
can be pretty complex
so it is in turn a fairly powerful
system for handling these requirements
what about compared to vms well if you
run stuff in vms you have to manage all
those vms which can be quite a burden
you need to worry about where your
application is going on which vm you
have to worry about the health of those
vms and so on
kubernetes sits right in the middle of
this spectrum it's not too low level and
that make and it's not too high level
and that makes it very attract a very
attractive deployment platform for a lot
of users
add to this a few other properties like
the fact it's based on open source
technology so you can move your
deployments around and it becomes very
attractive indeed kubernetes can run
pretty much anywhere so you might be
running kubernetes on-prem you might be
running in other clouds using kubernetes
in all these environments makes your
deployments standardized and portable
so what are the actual components in
kubernetes that offer this flexibility
that makes it so attractive
kubernetes ships with many components
out of the box including deployment for
stateless web applications stateful set
for custom databases and anything else
that needs a persistent disk
for batch jobs there's the job object
if you need to run an agent on every
node such as to capture logs you have
the daemon set
added to this are some scheduling
constructs like zonal affinity and pod
topology spread patterns that allow you
to design your workload around failure
domains as well as priority and
preemption that give you fine-grained
access to the scheduling priority to
enable rapid scaling of high priority
workloads
at a technical level all these
constructs are represented in kubernetes
objects through the kubernetes api
you can describe a whole bunch of things
even at this level at the kubernetes api
level what zones you want to run in
or how you want to spread your pods for
fault tolerance
say if you want to co-locate two
different apps together on a node so
that each machine is running the front
end and back end application while at
the same time being spread out over zone
you can do that now kubernetes does have
a bit of a reputation for having a steep
learning curve
after all there's a lot of different
things here many of which i just talked
about and
that reputation may be somewhat deserved
but let me make a couple of claims
firstly
if you just need to deploy a simple web
application then as my colleague gary is
going to demonstrate it's not that hard
at all you only need to learn two api
constructs a deployment which houses
your code and a service which is how you
expose your application to the internet
that's it
so don't feel like you have to learn
everything all at once but know that
it's there if and likely when you need
it
and secondly as a professional you're
not necessarily always looking for the
simplest tools out there right
simple is good don't get me wrong but
what you really need are powerful tools
you want to make sure that the
deployment tools you are using can
actually deliver all the things that you
need to do
and kubernetes is really good at doing
that so i'd say it's worth learning
now one of the things that makes
kubernetes a little more challenging
though is that you traditionally need to
learn two systems
you need to learn the kubernetes
architecture that is the open source api
components above the line on the screen
here
and you also need to learn the platform
api like gkes
at the gke layer you create the cluster
and provision it with the compute
capacity your workloads need or set up
auto scalers to do that for you
and once created you have a shared
responsibility for those compute
resources and may need to debug node
issues from time to time
this is just how kubernetes works
and the overhead you incur for getting
the benefits and power of kubernetes
right
at least that's how it used to be
this is why we created autopilot for gke
autopilot joins what we now call the
standard mode of operation giving you
two ways to use gke
with autopilot most of the platform
details are handled for you
automatically
it's still the same gke that you know
and love we just now have a new way for
you to operate it
this is the cluster creation page for gk
autopilot
as you can see it's pretty simple
in fact these are all the settings you
need to get yourself a functioning
production grade cluster
you just need to give your cluster a
name pick the region and configure
network
so
hopefully coming up with a name isn't so
hard
as for the region you may have a
favorite already otherwise generally you
would just pick the one closest to your
users
for networking if you have public
networking you don't need to do anything
more
for private networks you just need to
specify your subnets and ranges like
normal
and that's it i mean that's really it
sure there's a couple of additional
security features that you can enable or
disable below the fold or you can just
accept our secure defaults and change it
later if you need to
importantly there is no node or auto
scaling setup needed just go ahead and
click the create button get your
production grade cluster
going back to the api view of the world
what does this mean
well basically we shrank the whole gke
api service down to a single call
the create call
as for the kubernetes api
which is how you represent your
workloads well that's still there
and this is really the point
our goal with autopilot is to support
most of those workloads that gke sander
does today in particular we still
support all those stateful workloads
that need a persistent disk
our goal here is not to change the
kubernetes api just the platform it runs
on
so how does this work
how can we still offer most of the
kubernetes features of gke standard
while reducing the platform api to just
the create function
well with autopilot you describe your
workloads in kubernetes terms as you
always have like your container image
and the resources it needs
once scheduled on a gke cluster running
in autopilot mode we'll automatically
figure out the node resources needed to
run those workloads and provision enough
capacity for you
for example if your container requests
two cpu cores and six gigabytes of
memory we'll provision a node big enough
to handle it
we apply the best practices that we've
learned from six years of running gte
giving a production grade cluster
without the hassle
so that's handy
but what about after the cluster is
created
this is actually where the real benefit
of autopilot comes in
with a traditional kubernetes platform
including gke's standard mode of
operation there is a shared
responsibility over the nodes
while gke standard handles the life
cycle of those nodes for example the
creation updating deleting and offers
several features to help automate like
auto repair at the end of the day those
nodes are still vms that you need to
manage you have admin access to them and
can potentially modify them to behave in
ways that gke might not expect
so for autopilot we looked at this and
asked
do you come to gke for the ability to be
the root user on those nodes or are you
primarily looking to run your own
applications on this platform
we believe for most the goal is to run
your own business applications so that's
what we offer here
in this mode you're responsible for
describing your workloads and running
them
if your workload crashes due to a bug in
your code
hate to say it it's still your problem
but most other components related to the
nodes are now google's responsibility
along with the cluster itself
this is a big deal
and so with this we introduced a pod
level sla for the first time on gke it's
three nines
this means you now have a cluster that's
easier to set up and easier to manage
so as a developer you're more productive
and in production you spend less time on
the minutiae of managing the thing and
more time running your application which
is presumably what you're ultimately
here to do
the third major difference with this
mode of operation is how resources are
built since you describe everything at a
pod level we bill you at a pod level as
well it's kind of intuitive and it
brings with it some nice benefits one
benefit is you don't have to be a
so-called kubernetes bin packing expert
because you no longer care if your node
has 32 pods or zero or whether your
node's cpu has been fully allocated or
not
because all of that is now our problem
our system is responsible for packing
pods onto nodes and if there's any
wasted spare capacity that's on us you
don't pay for it
so it's a really nice building model as
well
and with this comes another nice
attribute if you're running a multi-team
setup you can now figure out how much
each namespace costs just by adding up
all the pod requests in that namespace
and we even have tools to help you with
that
what's more is that autopilot comes with
a strong security posture right out of
the box we implement the gke hardening
guidelines and since the nodes are more
locked down in order for us to provide
management and that sla you have the
benefit of the reduced node surface area
as well
you won't need to worry about unpatched
nodes either since we will keep
everything updated automatically
and if automatic updates worry fear not
as we have several tools to manage that
as well including maintenance windows
and pod disruption budgets
so coming back to the kubernetes
workload constructs i presented earlier
and one of the main reasons why people
use kubernetes in the first place let's
have a look do they work on autopilot
the answer is for the most part yes
and in the same way
deployments stateful set jobs they all
work exactly the same way yes even that
complex stateful custom database will
just work on autopilot with no
additional platform specific
configuration needed you can move it
right on over
let me repeat this because it's so
important we understand that a lot of
users run stateful workloads in their
clusters so when we created autopilot we
didn't take any shortcuts here
everything just works for statefulset as
you would expect from gke
now since pods running on autopilot
don't have admin privileges it does
alter some use cases especially for
deployment for daemon sets but this is
mostly in the domain of administrative
functions the exact type of functions we
hope won't be needed anymore
and we've engaged several key partners
to deliver their solutions on autopilot
for logging monitoring and security in
the same way they work on gke standard
covering many of the popular daemon sets
that we see
there's a couple other features like
gpus which gk standard offers that's
currently lacking in autopilot
for the full list see our comprehensive
autopilot overview documentation i'll
put a link in the description below
so we launched autopilot about half a
year ago and companies like ubi are
already seeing the benefit of this
approach ubi if you haven't heard of
them yet it's an innovative medical
technology startup based in japan they
found that with autopilot they were able
to focus more on doing the thing that
they created their company to do which
is to build better healthcare solutions
and less on managing the cluster
and all the infrastructure
you can read all about this case study
on our website which i highly recommend
again i'll put a link in the description
below
and with that i want to hand it over to
my colleague gary who's going to run
through a practical demo using autopilot
over to you gary
thanks william
in this demo we'll try to deploy a
standard web application with a redis
backend on autopilot the application has
three services a redis leader with a
single replica a redis follower
which actually has three replicas
and a reddit and a front-end web
application
which has three replicas as well
now let's deploy this application
all right now let's check the status of
our pods
now notice that we have one in the ready
state and several in the pending state
that's because we actually don't have
enough compute resource provisioned in
the cluster but not to worry autopilot
will handle this for us
behind the scenes autopilot is actually
provisioning additional compute for us
let's take a look
you can see here we've added
one new node and we have two new nodes
in the provisioning status right now if
we take another look at our pods
we'll see that we actually have a couple
more in the container creating stage
we'll wait for a little bit but soon
we'll see all of our applications so all
of our pods will actually be deployed
all right let's check our pod status one
more time
all right all of our pods are running
we'll also notice we are now have five
nodes up and running as well uh to meet
the demands
now let's actually uh test out this
application
we need to get the address of the
front end application
all right we can see that the external
ip address here is that
we'll copy that
paste it into our browser
all right we have the guestbook
application
we'll type in a few messages here
all right we'll close this out
but if all is working we should uh see
these messages back again coming from
the cache
all right our application is up and
running all is well
now in this demo we showed the ability
of autopilot to automatically
dynamically provision compute as needed
by your workload we didn't get into auto
scaling but william's going to tell us a
bit about that and then i'll be back
with another demo to show you
that as well
thanks gary
so as gary showed autopilot will
automatically provision resources to
schedule your pods under the hood based
on the resources those pods request
but what about scaling the workloads
themselves
for this gk offers two pod level scaling
options
the vertical pod autoscaler can increase
and decrease the resources used by the
pod
it does this by monitoring the resource
utilization of the pod and can adjust
the pod request either increasing it to
improve performance when it notices more
cpu might be needed or decreasing it
when it sees that the cpu is being
underutilized
and with autopilot that's all you need
to do autopilot will ensure that you
have the right node resources available
to run those resized pods and of course
you only pay for the precise resource
requests of your pot
to enable in gke autopilot create a
vertical pod auto scaling object that
references your deployment you can
optionally exclude certain containers in
the pod from the vpa
i'll put a link to the documentation in
the description below
the other workload scaling option is the
horizontal pod autoscaler or hpa the
horizontal pod autoscale scaler can
change the number of pod replicas in
your deployment based on demand
with the horizontal pod autoscaler you
set a metric to observe and a target and
the hp will attempt to create more pod
replicas to keep that target in range
for example if you want to have one pod
for every 100 requests per second that
hit your load balancer it could do that
with gk autopilot you can just set and
forget this hpa and let it handle the
usage spikes for you as g as autopilot
will provision and de-provision
automatically the compute resources
needed to handle those parts and of
course as always you only pay for
running pods
to enable create a horizontal pod
autoscaling object that references the
deployment to be scaled
specifying the minimum and maximum
replica counts the metric to be observed
and your desired target
horizontal pod auto scaling can be
configured to use cpu memory or custom
metrics like requests per second or pub
sub q depth
now i'd like to hand it back to gary
who's going to show you a really cool
demo of using autopilot with a
horizontal pod autoscaler to handle a
pub sub cue
back over to you gary thanks william in
this demo we're going to show how to
auto scale a pub sub workload based on
metrics provided by google cloud
monitoring
as you can see we've already created a
topic named echo and a corresponding
subscription named echo read the goal
for this demo is to scale the number of
subscribers for this topic based on the
number of unacknowledged messages
remaining in the subscription as you can
see on the screen pub sub conveniently
provides this metric for us and later
we'll actually show how to configure the
horizontal auto horizontal pod auto
scaler to use it
now
this is all made possible by using the
custom metrics adapter which will
provide cloud monitoring metrics for our
cluster now while william was talking i
actually took the liberty of deploying
this adapter
so let's take a quick look
just to make sure everything's running
all right so now we see we have our
custom metrics adapter up and running
now we can actually check to make sure
that the metric that we want is
available
by querying
the kubernetes external metrics api
and here in the response you'll see that
we have our subscription number
undelivered messages metric and we
actually see that we have it for our
actual subscription so we'll be set up
to use this in the hpa later on
but before we can deploy our application
we'll need to configure an identity
the app can use to authenticate with
cloud pub sub
autopilot workloads use workload
identity which is the recommended way to
access google cloud services from
applications it provides improved
security and manageability over using
things like secrets or mounting token
files which are
insecure first let's create a dedicated
namespace for our application
great we'll use a namespace pub sub
next we'll need to create a service
account
that will actually use in our deployment
metadata
we'll call it pub sub service account
we also need to create a google cloud
service account
and we'll need to give it permission to
actually access
pubs up here you see we're giving it the
pub sub editor role
next we'll actually find those the
kubernetes service account with the
google service account
and finally we'll annotate the
kubernetes service account so that it
knows about this binding
now let's take a look at our actual
application itself
the actual application itself is a
simple app which uses the python sta sdk
to actually just pull messages from the
subscription
now our deployment for this application
is pretty simple we have a standard
container we're going to name it you
know pub sub
and as you can see here we've actually
chosen the service count under which
this particular
deployment will actually run
now along with that we also have a
horizontal pod auto scaler resource
and as you can see here
we showed this metric earlier we're
using the external metric
we're using the under
undelivered messages
we want this to be for echo read
subscription
and our goal here will be that we never
want to no matter how many subscribers
we have we want the average value of the
backlog to actually be five
[Music]
all right so let's actually deploy our
application
first we'll just
set the default namespace for our
context
then we'll actually deploy our pod
we'll check to make
sure our pod is running
all right we've successfully deployed
that
next
we'll actually deploy the hpa resource
let's take a quick look
here we can actually see that we have it
set up as a
a target of five that's what we can
figure it in there the min pods is one
and the max pilots are five and right
now we don't actually have any med uh
messages so the backlog is zero and our
deployment is actually fine
now let's actually generate some load
we'll do that by publishing about 100
messages to the topic itself
all right now that our message has been
there let's take a look at the hpa
itself
as you can see here
it's actually updated now right we
actually see that the value that it's
seeing here is 22 and it's looking for a
value of 5. so if we actually describe
the hba
we'll see that it actually wants to
trigger up
and auto scale our stuff up to the max
size of actual five
let's take a quick look at our pods
you'll see that we've now actually
scaled up to four pods and we have a
fifth pod pending so as you can see here
we were able to build an application
have it subscribe
set the metric
based on the unacknowledged backlog from
google cloud metrics and auto scale our
application
and once again the great thing here was
we didn't have to worry about any of the
underlying compute resources
required for this to actually work
all right you'll see that our container
is actually creating
and
yeah and that's about it for this demo
so thanks william back over to you
thank you gary that was a really
powerful demonstration of what autopilot
can do
all you need to do is add your
kubernetes workload and we'll take care
of everything else
well that's gke autopilot to learn more
you can visit the link on the screen or
those in the description below thank you
you